NICK BUONICONTI:
America has always stood
for being able to accomplish
great things.
And I accomplished more than
my fair share of great things.
♪ (SOFT PIANO MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
He was just competitive,
a ferocious fighter.
The guy just wouldn't give up.
CRIS COLLINSWORTH:  Nick's
a pit bull with everybody.
I thought
he just didn't like me.
Football opened up every door
I could imagine,
and then I got a phone call.
That is a life changing moment.
He did feel a lot
of responsibility
'cause his son was following
in his footsteps.
MAN: After Marc's injury,
Nick let the world know
that anything could be solved.
That was his life's mission.
LYNN BUONICONTI: I started
noticing differences in Nick.
He wouldn't remember
where he was that morning.
Everything is jumbled for me.
People can see I'm not
the person I used to be.
He's had a remarkable life.
He's changed things, you know?
He's changed things.
My legacy will not be
on the field.
It will be off the field.
♪ (MUSIC CONCLUDES) ♪